hey I'm Paul Dietrich with reason TV
Donald Trump is a racist xenophobic
monster and you'd think there'd be a lot
more protesters out here in public
square and Cleveland but there's not
there's a lot of journalists and it
feels pretty lame that is a little
disappointing I don't know why more
people aren't physically here to express
their opinions but maybe they're
dependent on somebody else to do it for
them and put it on Facebook I'm here by
myself spreading the message of love and
I use my costume to start conversations
I have been to events that have been
advertised with happening someplace and
they have not happened because for
whatever reason they got canceled yep
and the year when convention protesters
are up against a maggot filled rotting
tangerine this is the best they could
come up with to combat Trump's
xenophobic racist messages no pens no
walls we build bridges no pens no walls
wait build bridges it's morning we found
a beauty pageant to highlight the irony
and Donald Trump's position thank you
all so we are saying that there is no
beauty in GOP hate there is no beauty
and racism in hatred and homophobia
there is no beauty in hatred policies
and having 8 in our colleges
this is an act of civil disobedience 13
people on a stage where only five are
allowed a fake beauty pageant seriously
lefty protesters where your hunger
strike source it ends where your armies
of the night ready to take on this
[ __ ] people are scared because this
is an open carry state and because
assault weapons are not banned in the
state or in this country people are
scared and as peace activists we have to
stand strong and nonviolent against that
yeah but now the peace activists are you
it looks like you guys are losing when
you should be winning you should be
winning this I agree we should be
winning but every small step is a giant
step for peace but that giant step might
not be enough up against Donald Trump's
red hat public relations army the days
most rowdy protest might have been a
flag burning groundbreaking gesture 25
years ago yep the cameras outnumber the
demonstrators by a wide margin a protest
for immigrants showed some spark but
they were outnumbered by story Hungary
reporters trying to cover them and
wouldn't you know it in the midst of
everything those reporters lost interest
to point their cameras at the guy in the
trump hat for reason TV I'm Paul
Dietrich
the bus will never be as strong as a
wall art